Check check check check.
[Music]
>> Oh yeah. Okay.
Okay.
[Music]
Scarlet.
Hey, hey, hey.
[Music]
Wondering just as we were wrapping up.
Hello.
[Music]
Back off.
me and you.
>> Oh, I'm excited about this.
with me.
>> The vertical stripes are
Yeah.
>> Good evening. Hello everyone.
Is everybody makes their way in? How is
everyone?
Wonderful. I'm so glad to hear that.
Hello online friends. I'm happy to see
you as well.
Um, as we get started tonight, um, a
couple of things. October, if you did
not know, is, um, domestic violence
awareness month. Um, and our friend
Marcy has been nice enough to provide
some reminder bracelets over on the
wooden table. Um, domestic violence will
affect 24 people by the time I'm done
talking and it will affect one in
three and 10 women and one in 10 men um,
over their life. So, it is prevalent. It
is there every day. Um, and if you'd
like to be reminded to pray about that
or keep it online this month, there are
some lovely bracelets over on the wooden
table. Um, so feel free to grab one. Um,
also in announcements. Um,
next weekend is our North Texas Pride
booth. So over in Plano, we're going to
be at the North Texas Pride Festival
there. Um, we'll have a booth. We're
still looking for a few volunteers. So
if you want to sign up, you can do that
online um, via the QR code. So, uh, feel
free to check that out as well. It will
be a great time if you like meeting
people and just being a smiling face
really. You don't even have to. People
are just happy to see somebody and shake
a hand sometimes. So, um, after that,
uh, Fall Fest is coming around the
corner. So, uh, families on October
17th, that is a Friday, uh, kids through
sixth grade will be having a fun night
of pumpkin carving and painting at the
Runford home in Saxi. There will be
games and snacks as well as a contest
for pumpkin carving. Um, you can sign up
online for that as well.
And then new announcement, chili cookoff
November 2nd. So it'll be our sixth
anniversary here at the table. Um, and
we do a chili cookoff that will be in
the gym, I'm guessing, probably. Um, you
can sign up and register there. Um, I'll
tell you a secret. I've won two years in
a row, but um, I love a good challenge.
So, um, please come have lots of chili.
There are lots of options. Brett makes a
mean vegan chili. Um, so there will be
all sorts of things there for you to eat
and we look forward to the happy social
time that will be. Um, so as we shift to
worship,
may these candles be a sign of presence
of Christ both among us uh physically
and spiritually.
And
let me Listen
to that. Now we exit the kingdom of
voice, hurry and productivity.
We enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity. Sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and
adoration. A place to behold Christ,
revelation of God,
heartbeat of creation. Allow the
unforced of grace to find you, to mend
your heart. May we all come home.
Thank you, Jared. If you guys want to
stand with us, we're going to start off
with Dra singing. You guys sing along.
[Music]
Test test. Y'all got me out there now.
All right,
you guys join us. We're going to start
off with a day for singing tonight. So,
stand if you would like. Sit back and
enjoy. But let's sing some praises to
the Lord.
[Music]
Sing mercy,
mercy
rising. With the rising above the sun,
[Music]
a goodness
rationing in filling up my love.
Your faithfulness, your faithfulness
is here and now.
The evidence
is all around.
I'll bless your name. I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
[Music]
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord.
Today is a day for singing. Oh my soul.
Oh
my soul.
Praise
the Lord.
Oh
my soul,
today is a day for singing.
[Music]
A new song
is well enough from deep inside of me.
There is new life.
Hallelujah. I have been redeemed. I've
been redeemed.
I bless your name. I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul. Come on, praise the Lord.
Today is a day for singing. Oh,
oh
my soul.
Praise
the Lord.
Oh my soul. Oh
my soul,
>> today is a day for singing.
Today,
today is a day for singing
[Music]
from the valley to the mountain, theert.
Oh, I will praise you
from the morning to the evening. As long
as I can brea in. Today is a day for
singing. And sing it out. From the
valley to the mountain, the desert to
the fountain. Today is a day for
singing.
And from the morning to the evening, as
long as I am breathing, today is a day
for singing. Today, today, today is a
day for singing. Sing. I bless your
name. I bless your name. I give you
praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord.
Today is a day for singing. Sing, oh my
soul,
oh
my soul,
>> praise
the Lord,
oh my soul,
>> oh
my soul,
today is a day for singing, oh my soul,
>> from the valley to the mountain, the
desert to the fountain. mountain. Oh, I
will praise the Lord
from the
soul. I grieving.
>> Today is a day for singing. Today,
today, today is a day for singing.
>> Oh, today today is a day for singing.
[Music]
All right, kids. You guys are dismissed
to go to your classes. So, you can meet
your teachers right over here by the
doors. We're so glad for all of our
children and all of our children's
workers who help each week love on these
guys and teach them about the love of
God and their identity in Christ. So,
thank you guys so so very much.
[Music]
And tonight, you might have noticed
we're set up a little bit different than
our norm. Um, because you are here for
our very first table night of worship.
And I'm really excited about it. We've
been doing a lot of prep behind the
scenes. And I really hope that this will
be a time for us to connect in a
different way than we normally have the
space and time to do. Um, so just for a
start, you might notice there's some
white sticky notes over on that back
wall and there are cups of markers along
the ledge there and I think there's one
on the floor under those. We have a
couple different stations and ways to
connect. Um, I know not everyone is uh a
music person. Um, some people are not
into the singing and um, all the
physical interaction that comes along
with music and that expression, but we
all connect with God. He has made each
one of us to connect with him in a
unique way. And we want to provide
different ways to do that tonight. So,
we have the sticky notes back there and
those markers. Feel free to mark up
those papers or write whatever you want.
If there's something on your heart, a
prayer, another verse that comes to
mind, if you like doodling, you like
drawing. They're back there for you. Um,
please add to them however you'd like.
We have um pillows and yoga mats down
here on the floor for those of you who
just feel like it might be helpful for
you to get into your body a little bit
if you need to lay out and rest, relax,
and just soak in some of the music
tonight. You are welcome to do that in
that space and take it in that way. Um,
stretch out, do what you need. Um, we
have communion already preset up here
along this wall. So, there's a bread um
in a cup and a cup of wine. Um and you
can come at any point in the night
whenever you would like up to the front
and you can kneel there at the altar and
take your communion or you could take it
back to your seat um or around the room.
This space is open for you to connect
the way that you need to connect
tonight. Um we also have our friend Lily
over here. I'm so grateful she agreed to
do some live art for us during our
worship night. And I just encourage you
to take space during the night tonight
to go observe, watch. Even the process
of art is something that it's hard for
us sometimes to open ourselves up to
that process in our own lives. And for
me, watching someone else do that can be
so helpful. It grounds us in a way that
like touches different um different like
nerves, different neurons in my brain
that I just I need to be stimulated by
um instead of just our normal flow. It's
so beautiful to take in someone who's
who's committed themselves to this craft
of creating and the vulnerability that's
required there. So, I just encourage you
guys to enjoy that. Um, I think I've
named all our stations. So, we're going
to go ahead and just keep rolling and
jump right in. I'm just going to read
this verse out of Psalms I mean sorry uh
John 7. Um it says on the last and day
and and greatest day of the feast, Jesus
stood and said in a loud voice, "If
anyone is thirsty,
let him come to me and drink."
If anyone is thirsty,
let him come to me and drink. Whoever
believes in me, as the scriptures has
said, streams of living water will flow
within him.
Streams of living water will flow from
Jesus,
I'm stepping into this space tonight,
thirsty for your presence.
This world is full of brokenness and
pain. And we each have our story, God.
We're each carrying in our story and our
baggage and our struggles, our sins,
our confusion.
And tonight, God, I just want to offer
all that up and ask you to meet us right
in the center of it.
We don't push it to the side, God, but
we instead lift it to you as a burnt
offering.
We lift it to you and say, "Come, God,
with your peace. Come with your clarity.
Come with your presence and your spirit,
God, and fill us up
with living water
that satisfies
[Music]
Where can we run?
Where can we hide?
You will not find us
in the deepest of depths and the highest
of heights.
Your love it chases
us.
No matter where we've been,
no matter what we've done,
we can't escape
your love.
Oh,
but we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
Oh.
Though we pass through the fire and we
pass through the flood,
you will be with
us, God.
Though we walk through the valley, in
the darkest of night,
your love will be
our light.
When we are in plenty and when we are in
want,
you will always be
there.
>> Oh,
and we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your good. Sing that one more time.
Yes. We will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
Oh.
We'll never see you. We'll never see the
end.
And in the darkest hour and on the
hardest days,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises that you have made.
And in our darkest hour and in our
hardest days,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave.
You will not forsake.
The promises that you have made
and we can say
that we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
I'll never see the end.
Never see the end.
[Music]
Let's sing. Glory,
glory, glory,
hallelu
Jesus, you are good.
Glory, glory,
hallelu
Jesus, you are good. Sing that out to
him. Glory,
glory,
hallelu
Jesus, you are good. Oh, we sing glory,
glory,
hallelu.
Jesus, you are God.
[Music]
Word can wash away my sins.
Nothing but the blood of Jesus.
What can make
whole again?
Nothing but the blood of Jesus.
Oh
precious.
is the flow
that makes me white. I s
[Music]
know
nothing but the blood of Jes. Oh
precious,
oh
preious.
He's the one
that
makes me wise.
[Music]
I know
that in the blood of Jesus
[Music]
of Jesus.
>> Oh yes.
[Music]
[Applause]
>> Nothing perfect.
ab up above
and glory, glory,
hallelu
Jesus, you are good. Sing it to him.
Glory, glory,
hallelujah.
Jesus, you are,
>> you are good. You are good.
Glory, glory,
hallelu
[Music]
Jesus,
you are good. We sing glory,
glory,
hallelu
Jesus, you are good.
[Music]
Oh, you are good.
So good to me. So good to me. It's why
we sing.
[Music]
And we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
[Music]
We'll never see
the end
of your love. It never runs out.
Oh God, we're thirsty for you.
Thirsty
for you.
We are
living
water flowing
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your livinging
water flowing from the heart of the
father.
Jesus we want your living
water
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living
water flowing from the heart of the
father.
Jesus, we want your living water,
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we watch your living water
Jesus, we want your living water
from
>> the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living water flowing
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want you.
[Music]
We want you.
God is our refuge and our strength,
[Music]
an everpresent help in trouble.
Therefore, we will not fear.
Though the earth give way,
though the mountains fall into the heart
of the sea,
though its waters roar and foam, and the
mountains quake with their surging.
There is a river whose streams make glad
the city of God.
The holy place where the most high
dwells.
God is within her. She will not fall.
God will help her at break of day.
Nations are in uproar.
Kingdoms fall.
He lifts his voice.
The earth melts.
The Lord Almighty is with us. The God of
Jacob is our fortress.
[Music]
Living water
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your livinging water
Jesus, we want you
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living
water.
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living water flowing
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living
water flowing from the heart of the
father.
Jesus, we want your living water flowing
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your livinging water
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living water,
Jesus, we want your livinging water
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living water flowing
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living water
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want your living
water
flowing from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we want you.
[Music]
Yes, God.
All my words fall short.
I got nothing new.
How could I express
all my gratitude?
I could sing these songs
[Music]
as I ofen do.
Every song must stand
and you never do.
[Music]
Oh, I throw up my hands. Praise you
again and again.
Cuz all that I have is a hallelujah.
[Music]
Hallelujah.
And I know it's not much. I've nothing
else fit for a king.
Except for a heart singing hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
[Music]
I've got one response.
I've got just one
with my arms stretched wide
and I will worship you.
So I throw up my hands and praise you
again and again.
All that I have is a hallelujah.
And I know it's not much. I've nothing
else fit for a king
>> except for a heart singing hallelujah.
[Music]
Come on my soul. Oh, don't you get shy
of me. Lift up your song cuz you've got
a lion inside of those lungs. Get up and
praise the Lord.
[Music]
Come on my soul. Oh, don't you get shy
on me. Lift up your song. You got a lion
inside of those lungs. Get up and praise
the Lord.
Oh, come on my soul. Oh, don't you get
shy on me. Lift up your soul.
You've got a lion inside of those lungs.
Get up and praise the Lord.
Oh
[Music]
yeah.
Oh,
[Music]
I've still got joy in chaos.
I've got peace that makes no sense. So I
won't be going under.
I'm not held by my own strength. Cuz I
built my life on Jesus.
And he never let me down. He's faithful
in every season.
So why would he fail now?
He was
[Music]
He won't fail.
He won't.
Oh,
he won't fail.
[Music]
He won't.
You won't
give up on this.
We won't give up on you.
[Music]
My house was built on you.
And I'm safe with you.
I'm going make it through.
Sing that again. Rain came,
but my house was built on you.
And I'm safe with you.
I'm going to make it through.
Came with blue. My house was built on
you.
I stay with you. I'm going to make it
through.
I'm going to make it through. Cuz
I'm standing strong on you.
>> I'm going to make it through.
>> You going to make it.
>> My house was built on you.
>> Christ is rock.
>> Christ is my firm foundation.
>> The rock on which I stand. When
everything around me is shen,
I've never been more
that I built my faith in Jesus
and he's never let me down. He's
faithful through generations.
[Music]
So why would he fail down?
>> He
won't.
[Music]
He won't fail.
>> He won't fail.
Sing. You won't. You won't.
You won't.
>> You won't.
[Music]
You won't fail.
Yeah. I'm going to make it through.
Cuz I'm standing strong on you.
I'm going to make it through.
>> My house was built on you.
>> I'm going to make it through.
>> I'm standing
on you.
>> I'm going make it through.
[Music]
My house was built for you.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community, and all
who live in them, we pray to you
for the good earth that you've given us,
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it. We pray to you for the old and the
sick, for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you
for the vulnerable, the marginalized,
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender, their sexuality, race, or other
perceived difference. We pray to you for
those experiencing loss, loneliness and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you,
Lord. We know that you love us and that
you hear us. So we lift these names and
situations up to you.
[Music]
Angel.
Are you
[Music]
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence.
Amen.
[Music]
Would
you take Lord and receive
my liberty?
My meories
[Music]
and my will. All that I call my home.
Give
me
only
your loving grace.
Your love
is enough.
>> That is enough
[Music]
for
me.
[Music]
You have given all to me. To you, Lord,
I return
it.
Everything
belongs to you. do with it. What you
can
be
only
[Music]
your loving grace.
That is enough.
[Music]
>> That is enough
for
me.
For
[Music]
There's a grace when the heart is under
fire.
the other way when the walls are closing
in.
[Music]
When I look at the space between where I
used to be in this reckoning,
I know I will never be alone.
There was another in the fire
standing next to me. There was another
in the
holding back the sea.
Should I ever need
[Music]
>> across the
fore?
There is another in the fire.
[Music]
All my dead left for dead beneath the
wall.
I'm no longer a slave to insin.
Should I fall in the space between what
remains of me in this reseers
[Music]
holding back the sea. Should I ever need
reminding
the power set me free, there is a grave
that holds nobody.
Now the power lives in me. There is
another in the fire.
Oh,
there is another in the fire.
I can see the light in the darkness as
the darkness bows to him. I can hear the
roar in the heavens as a space between
there. I can feel the ground shake
beneath us as a prison walls gave in.
Nothing stands between us.
[Music]
There is no other name but the name that
is Jesus.
[Music]
>> He who was and still lives and will be
through it all.
Come what may in the space between all
the things unseen and this reckoning.
I know I will never be alone.
I know
There'll be another in the fire
standing next to me. There'll be another
in the water
holding back the seas
should I ever need my
good you been to me.
Come the joy from every battle cuz I
know that's where you'll be. I can say I
can see the light in the darkness as the
darkness bows to heaven. I can feel the
roar in the heaven as a space between.
I can feel the ground shake to keep us
as a prison walls created. Nothing
stands between us.
Nothing stands between us.
Jesus.
How I trust you. Now I prove
glory.
Jesus.
Precious
Oh grace to trust him more.
And I can see the light in the darkness
as the darkness bows to him. I can hear
the roar in the heavens as a space
between.
I can feel the
as
nothing between us.
Nothing stands between us. Be another in
the fire.
Standing next to me will be another in
the water.
holding back the seas. And should I ever
needed
how good you've been to me,
count the joy come every battle.
I know that's where you'll be.
Count the joy come every battle.
>> Cuz I know that's where you'll be.
>> Count the joy come every battle.
I know that's where you'll be.
[Music]
We trust you, God.
Jesus, thank you for meeting us, each
one of us in your way
with your goodness and your mercy, your
faithfulness,
your creativity,
your beauty,
[Music]
God, it's why we sing. It's why we
worship.
It's why we take space in our day to
invite you in. God, to find you,
to seek you out. God, would you fix our
eyes on you, the author, the perfector
of our faith?
When the world around us is sinking
sand,
when the mountains fall into the heart
of the sea,
God, would we find your stream of living
water that makes glad our hearts?
Would you be right beside us, God?
Closer than our skin.
[Music]
Thank you for this time together.
Thank you for being a good God.
[Music]
We love you, Jesus.
We're going to wrap up and I'm going to
send you guys out with a benediction.
Um, and then after that, you're free to
go get your kids. Um, we hope to see you
at Hat Creek. But also, I wanted to make
a small note. Um, we're wrapping up just
a few minutes early. We have a little
bit of setup that needs to happen to get
this room back the way it belongs for
um, the church that so graciously hosts
us. So, if anyone is available and would
like to stick around and help us set
some chairs back up, Scott Marlor in the
back is your man. He will tell you where
things go, what to do, how we could
pitch in and help him out. Um, but other
than that, we hope to see you guys at
Hat Creek. And thank you guys for being
a part of our first worship night. I
hope that it was um some refreshing
water to your soul. If you would like to
stand with me now, if you're able and uh
you're welcome to hold your hands out or
just accept this in your heart.
[Music]
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day. So as you go
into your week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between, go filled with the assurance
that you are loved, you are worthy, and
you are accepted just as you are. and go
filled with the with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with.
We will see you guys at Hat Creek.
[Music]
There you go.